[Musique]
bienvenue ici faire des Skywest on est
le petit dernier bébé donc de la marque
ici nous proposons une vingtaine de
pistes de bowling on a aussi un laser
game
des box karaoké et du billard et une
grande salle d'arcade
[Musique]
pour la première fois au monde une piste
de karting qui passe dans un centre
commercial dans l'atrium des cartes 100%
électrique avec deux modes de jeux soit
de la course classique ou du jeu de type
game of cards le principe c'est qu'il y
a les cibles qui sont apparents sur la
du crochet sur la piste vous voulez
dessus et à chaque fois que vous voulez
dessus il y a un bonus qui s'affiche sur
l'écran vous l'activer et le but est de
ralentir tous vos adversaires donc
vraiment du jeu ce n'est pas ce n'est
plus de la course c'est implanté sur
Skywest 50 ans en Yvelines parce qu'il y
a une très très grande
vie étudiante donc c'est ça qui est
important et à basse en entreprise peut
aussi très important
[Musique]
on vient d'entendre Joachim Thomas pires
le directeur de speed Park Skywest qui
nous a expliqué le principe des
différentes activités parmi elles il y a
le karting Mathilde et oui le karting la
piste est juste derrière nous Nicolas on
va s'affronter tous les deux il y aura
avec nous Grégory canalet Céline Charles
lou Daddy et William Morel nos deux
c'est-à-dire qu'ils nous ont rejoint
pour ce défi atte dans des coups de
Nicolas
[Musique]
franchement c'est génial ça peut vous
pouvez partir dernier et arriver premier
à la fin c'est juste stratégique en fait
je suis un peu dégoûtée je me suis
planté dans le virage là et du coup je
les ai tous perdu alors que j'étais
deuxième et que je leur ai envoyé plein
de bombes mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
le jeu
[Musique]
et ben voilà Nicolas je sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé mais moi je me suis
vraiment bien amusée
avec les bonus les malus ça change
vraiment tout le jeu en fait c'est pas
un karting normal exactement c'est pas
le meilleur pilote qui vient mais c'est
peut-être le plus stratège et je vous ai
senti très stratégie j'ai essayé j'ai
essayé un moment donné voilà et donc
vous avez vu le quartier vous avez pu
voir aussi sur les images les jeux
d'arcade le karaoké le bowling il y a
plein de choses à faire ici à speed Park
Skywest est ouvert 7 jours sur 7 en fin
d'après-midi jusqu'à maximum deux heures
du matin